salut auparavant dans les événements de
la journée avait pour cadre la ville de
montfermeil une manifestation et une
ambiance plutôt tendue avec sur place
brigitte fanny cohen scène d'un racisme
peu ordinaire à la sortie des classes à
montfermeil
les dernières mesures discriminatoires
du maire contre les écoles maternelles
ont mis de l'huile sur le feu
on commence à dire tout ce qu auparavant
on pensait tout bas
si c'est oublier que les enfants qui
naissent ici normalement son français
avec algérien là on discutait avec un
groupe label du nord monsieur arad fini
estime sarah ben voilà alors que c'est
considère prendre des photos dans ce
pays devant l'école beaucoup de parents
préfèrent ne paraît pauvre peut être
intimidé par la présence de deux
policiers en civil
une étrange ambiance s'est installé à
montfermeil au quotidien le racisme et
la peur tant qu'elle sera c'est ce que
je mettrais pas l'école mon fils j'ai
peur que ce système en face à l'école
c'est bon ca du feu aussi à quoi que ce
soit en n'importe quoi ici à l'école
victor hugo qui accueillent 90%
d'enfants d'origine étrangère tout est
calme en apparence mais les
institutrices refuse de parler devant la
caméra
l'inspection académique a donné des
consignes autre élément dissuasif
ce sont les lettres anonymes qu'elles
ont reçues lettre de menace ou d'
insulte pour avoir accepté en classe des
enfants d'immigrés ce soir le parti
communiste a organisé un rassemblement
de protestation
les manifestants ont tous réclamé la
démission immédiate du maire de
montfermeil